you definitely have the coolest name as
your zoom name
you know what happened is just a couple
days ago i think it must have been an
update i had to do a call right away and
it said you have to sign in but it's
been defaulting to that ever since so i
can't even take it off
listen
you're not going to get better than that
so my favorite kurt russell story real
quick i was hanging out with kurt and he
goes i was going i don't know about
snake plisket of course and he goes
watch this and he showed me his iphone
my son taught me how to do this and he
hits the siri button and goes who am i
you're snake pliskin aren't you
i'm the only one who can do that
he was so proud of that that is amazing
is that a great story but i'm a phony
obviously because i can't say that i
can't say i'm saying this but he
couldn't see that sometimes you're
talking to someone that you're just such
a huge fan of and you're sitting across
from them and you just can't believe
you're doing it yeah that's definitely
he's one of those guys because he's jack
burton too he talks a lot like jack
burton
so it was funny to see him embrace the
snake pliskin that much because he was
just like he had it as his identity on
his phone that's hilarious
uh i have a bunch of questions for you
but i wanted to start i wanted to start
with um first congrats it must have been
our interview that led to the success of
we can be heroes um
clearly it was it was the collider
conversation but only
seriously though congrats on the success
of that um
did netflix sort of say to you after
that opening weekend um we love you and
when are we getting the next one
they've been shocked at how well it's
kept doing they're still like they call
it unstoppable they've never seen any
movie behave like that
it just will not stop kids will just not
stop watching it and i knew that about
the spike in movies
but you couldn't ever keep track of it
because people
can't tell how many times people kids
watching vcr
or watch on disney channel
but now with their metrics you know they
can tell how many times a household is
watching something again and yet through
completion which a lot of the times when
they have it's been a big opening
weekend it didn't mean people actually
watched the whole movie it means they
watched five minutes or more and a lot
of times people so the completion rate
was really high but also the repeat rate
was just off the charts because kids
just
will watch it in the morning before
school and after school
every day
so yeah they definitely want sql which
i'm working on because it's uh it's a
new franchise for them it behaves very
strange very differently but it's just
kids just crave empowerment and those
movies just hit those buttons
yeah last question on that do you do you
see yourself do you think it's
definitely filming a sequel or you're
definitely filming a sequel next year
are you going to direct it oh absolutely
i love making those folks they're so
creative the adults have a great time
too most of the adults in the cast had
kids too that couldn't watch any of
their movies so it's a great building of
the world and my own children work on
the films so it's like a family affair
it's family time you're making products
for other families
and uh you like checking all the box
living the best life
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you today um for the for this project
that you're doing for that you did for
disney plus um how did this thing land
how did this happen for you was this
something that was presented to you did
you go and can you sort of talk about
the genesis yeah the genesis is that i i
wanted to do some more and more stuff
like we can be here it's where i'm
working with my family
because that's mentoring them and
working like kids being with my kids my
daughter
did all the drawings that also draws and
could be heroes uh on the set and she
was a huge billy eilish fan she's saying
in the movie we can be heroes and
whenever we jam songs together i'd say
who wrote this song that's been another
billy eilers saw it wow she's amazing
over the years
she's 15 now um i had done a lady gaga
video last year with ariana grande and
the same person who hooked me up with
that
um called me about this billy project
and said
i would love you to help billy with this
project because we've done so much you
know like elita and motion capture and
you know volume things like mandalorian
um she wants to do something with an
animated character going through
hollywood and have a concert kind of
interwoven with a concert great go ask
my daughter you want to do something
with billy islands with me
because she got to do animation there's
animated my daughter animates we can
come up with animation ideas together we
can you know be listening to the album
before anybody get to meet billy her
idol and um so
we took it on and billy herself is just
fantastic so generous so sweet from a
great family
super talented her and her brother
phineas the album was amazing uh it was
going to be done in sequential order we
were going to have to shoot at the bowl
with no audience which means we were
able to move the camera
for every song all the cameras where
usually when you shoot a concert film
the cameras have to kind of stay in
their spot because you can't be moving a
crane from one side of the arena to the
next during the songs um
so we were able to drones over places
you never could get where i but it put a
reflecting pullback in that was in
originally when it was built that has
never been there since they used to use
that for seats it reflects the ball back
into itself so it becomes a circle just
really graphically awesome
and then
motion capturing billy and working with
her to make this animated character go
through la it was just a fun you know i
love doing different types of projects
you know just it helps me with my main
stuff that i do to learn from other
artists in a completely different world
so i'm always playing hooky it uh it
just gives you a more well-rounded
education and working with such
visionary young people um just gives you
ideas too i always consider myself a
student so i can come in with things i
know how to do but i'm there to really
have a front seat my daughter and i
watching
billy and phineas just rule and you know
it's done in sequential order so she
doesn't use any old songs
it's really not many artists can just do
one album from start to finish
live and have that be a concert and have
it be satisfied so she's
really just at the top of her game when
did you actually film this
beginning of july so it wasn't long ago
very fast that's the other thing i love
about the music world is i like to shoot
really fast myself
but because i think filmmaking can be
tedious and slow music worlds would
never stand for how slow even my speed
would be
they move so fast i love the energy of
it i got the call i think maybe in april
or may
and we didn't even start capturing until
near the end of june
that means the animation had to be done
in weeks not years you know so
everybody was just lying
and i think that's just gives it a real
energy
so uh
yeah this came together very quickly so
i'm curious because i've seen footage
from the um from the i guess it's a i
don't know what is it it's not a movie
what would you call this is it a movie
it's a concert film um
special because it's not just a concert
film and
it doesn't even look like a concert film
because of the way we're able to shoot
it but it's done live she left me there
singing at the time and um so it's a
live concert experience
but with animated storyline interwoven
throughout it yeah
i see what i'm curious about is so you
film this in early july and you're at
the hollywood bowl which is around a lot
of people what time of night were you
filming and was anyone nervous that the
music was going to leak before the album
came out
because it's only in headphones
because you only blasted it out for an
audience
everyone who was privileged to hear it
like my daughter and i were wearing
headphones billy's got you know any
performer on stage always has the
earwigs to hear because the monitors are
not reliable you need to have a good mix
when you perform any performer
performs with the
with the full mix in their ears so they
can hear themselves or if they need
their voice up higher they can you can
customize it for each performer so
everything's being recorded there she's
singing but you're not hearing it
projected so that's pretty cool right so
we had you know a partial audience that
would have blown it because people would
have heard it
yeah i was wondering and so what time
were you filming at like 8 p.m what
the sun was setting sometimes we want to
get the sunset shots
um and we could split it up you know a
few songs per night so we can do the
orchestras in there move them in and out
some of it's with la philharmonic and
you know gustavo
awesome stuff with that some stuff is
just them
more intimate with this huge awesome
space the lighting that goes into it
everything to be lit differently per
song
different coverage per song it's really
a cool show it um it does not feel
repetitive it is very each song is like
an experience it's really great how many
cameras were you actually using um at
the bowl in total to capture the event i
don't remember how many cameras that's a
good question because we had a big drone
flying too which you couldn't get some
of those shots if you had an audience
underneath it so that was awesome
because really when you see that
reflecting pull and what the dome does
in it it is really cool so we were
really shooting the heck out of it we
had several cranes
drone steadicams
uh eleven to ones there's probably a
good 10 to 12 cameras i would say billy
also has directed in the past and
obviously is very
specific with her vision of things um
i've heard her talk about it can you
sort of talk about collaborating with
her in terms of what she wanted versus
what you wanted and the melting pot of
how it came together yeah i'm very much
a facilitator when it comes to stuff
like this it's like i know i can help
her do things that she's not going to
have time to do and if she's like motion
capturing she can't see herself she'll
need somebody there who understands that
who can help direct her and get there
faster
so
yeah we we built the trust really early
on when i brought her some of the ideas
that i thought could enhance some of the
ideas that she had and give it a
direction just something for her to play
she loved that so we were just pretty
much in lockstep going forward but i
would always defer with any artist i'm
working with you know i would throw them
an idea if they like it let's do it if
not it might trigger an answer will they
say well i wasn't thinking that i was
thinking maybe this and that's the
direction we'd go so
i i i know to bring enough of a plan
that if nobody has any ideas we gotta
put marching orders but um i'm always
open to i really want her ideas more
than mine because it's gotta reflect her
her completely
just like when i would work with quinton
or or jim or um frank miller you know i
i i want to see
frank millerson city not robert
rodriguez and sin city i want to see
billy is version of this
concert experience and i can help make
it happen but that's mainly how i
approach it
you [ __ ] besides your daughter uh who
obviously is a very large fan did you
let anybody know that you were filming
this and did you all of a sudden find
that a lot of friends and family wanted
to visit you when you were filming the
special i didn't tell anybody we kept it
very secret but once it was announced
that we were doing it then i started
getting emails but we'd already shot it
by
can i come be a fly in the wall can i
get in on the concert i was like we
already shot it sorry i had suddenly had
friends that i hadn't heard from in 20
years suddenly writing me
um before i run out of time with you i
obviously you know that i have loved
your work on star wars thanks i
appreciate that
you you know i loved your boba fett
episode um i am i am curious though can
you sort of talk about because obviously
you're an integral part of book of boba
fett can you sort of just talk about how
you got involved in that series after
working on the mandalorian
can't say anything about it at all right
now
but it's coming out in december just
wait you see what's coming
it's it's going to blow your mind that's
all i can say that's all i can say and i
can talk it up all i want because i know
it over delivers it way over delivers so
you're going to be people are going to
be so pumped up on this deal you have
always tried to push technology with all
of the things you've worked on and one
of the things that the volume technology
is in its infancy and you know obviously
john and dave did amazing stuff with it
on the mandalorian you've now worked
with it a number of times can you sort
of talk about what you think the volume
technology can now
bring to storytelling that maybe you
couldn't do before and how has working
on it now multiple times
allowed you to sort of see the
technology in a new light so maybe
you're refining it you know and and
making it help what you want to do
yeah i mean it's interesting i'm trying
to think about what i could ever use it
for myself i think it really does help
the most like on something like a series
where you could have
i mean it means it gets easier and you
can just keep creating different loads
maybe not but at first i thought maybe
it made the most sense for a series
because you could have loads that you
could reuse and
places you can come back to often that
would be impossible to get to on a
regular basis in a series
i don't know if i would use it very much
in a movie
where it's just one-off
scenes that are done
they're only a couple minutes long and
then you never go back to that location
again like in a sequel to we could be
heroes even i was thinking would i even
use the volume or would i shoot a
traditional green screen again because i
got some pretty cool stuff what's what's
different about volume is you have to
you still have to do the work
of the visual effects it's am i going to
do it before i shoot or am i going to do
it after on a tv series you can pretty
much figure out you're going to need
these certain things on a movie i like
green screen more so i can punt it to
later what that thing's going to look
like i can kind of start lighting the
foreground with the kids 11 kids in the
foreground
i can like that on a set and then really
dial in the background later i'd have i
did that volume
i'd have to figure all that out in
pre-production that means that pushes
your movie shoot date really far back if
you have little kids those kids are
going to be so old by the time you
finish all your pre-production so it
kind of depends on the movie um and the
show and the tool i mean john found the
best way to use it for mandalorian
and and now boba fett and i think that
was a really great thing but i don't
think it's necessarily a tool that fits
every product
fits every project do you see yourself
directing mandalorian season three any
episodes i can't say that either
[Applause]
as a fan it's like i'm asking this as
the collider audience and as a fan you
know what i mean i wish i could tell
them but i can't say
all right so i'll switch subjects so i
won't get you in any trouble what's
going on with hypnotic and any other
movies you might be working on
hypnotically i mean it was supposed to
shoot last april and covet pushed it
like six months then it pushed again
because the covet came back strong and
now we're
fingers crossed shooting in six weeks
so
yeah i'm fingers crossed we're the
crew's now on so
we're prepping hard prepping so
i could be shooting that in the next six
weeks for fans can you sort of talk
about what the project is about that
maybe they don't know
it's like a hitchcock thriller on
steroids that's all i can say it's it's
as soon as you see the first trailer
you'll go i got it i'm i'm there you
know it's that kind of a move it's just
very a lot of twists a lot of turns
very exciting
not everything you see is real type show
and it's uh
it's got a great cast and it'll be very
energetic and
some of my favorite stories i started
writing back in 2002
so it's one of the ones i've i've had
the longest that i've been wanting to do
so i'm very excited that my friend
finally might be making it yeah if i'm
not mistaken you have ben affleck and
alice braga um
is that uh who else do you have or who
else have you announced well now we're
still we're casting now hardcast it was
hard to start casting until we knew for
sure we're going because the delta
variant showed up and we thought
this thing's going to push again because
it's an independently financed film
and you know like a disney plus could be
like we need this product we're filming
no matter what but you know you have an
independent film you have to get
insurance insurance companies they're
very
wary right now for this variant that
could shut a move down because they're
out of it they'll be out a lot of money
so um
understandably
it's risk so um
that we're going is is really exciting
because it's
it's going to be fun to shoot and uh
it's going to be a fun film i've been to
your studio in austin and you could
almost create a self-contained
environment depending on how many that's
exactly what we're doing most of it is
going to be on the law
majority
how does it work if you don't mind me
asking are you asking like the crew or
the talent that's going to be in the
movie to sort of bunker down in the area
or is it sort of one of those you can't
really decide what they do you know
offset but
but you
100 yeah they have to be
everyone's going to be tested and if
you're you're sick you have to be put
sent away or replaced or something you
can't we haven't shut the movie down so
fortunately i i work with as long as i
don't get sick you know i do a lot of
jobs myself
so uh and also just everyone's working
right now so it's hard to even get crew
so i'm having to do a lot of the jobs
myself again like the old days which is
fun so it's a blast
well you also have a you have a family
and you love working with them so just
be like son you know you're doing this
now yeah i know my son now is my
full-time composer
my other friend my co-writer producer my
daughter's doing storyboards my other
son's doing the uh
the animatics because he's using his
game engine stuff that he designed that
the sets for heroes with
and then my other son edits with me so
it's
family fair i just read that antoine
fuqua
shot the his jake gyllenhaal movie in
downtown l.a he'd been possibly exposed
and he directed from a van down the
street so he could be self-contained
he didn't end up getting covered but he
was you know possibly exposed so he
couldn't be on set
but and he ended up directing with like
you know a video village in his truck
with walkies i thought that that must be
possible if you don't kill like solely
horrible that
you can definitely direct from the
technology now like
like coppola used to do with from a
silver fish
or you could be in there with his
editing facility that that's the way to
do it
yeah
i was gonna say i gotta stop i've
totally gone over on time i'm just gonna
say um sincerely man it's always great
to talk with you thanks youtube